[Music]
in parenting made harder news submitted
by Chef of Joe Mallya that's my country
Joe Mallya you're welcome to go if you
want you have less hole like other earth
invented in your brain he does he's Elon
Musk Wow it's in the shape of a octagon
it's a little planet if Elon Musk was
like a little bit smarter and and in and
and more creative uh Asian with a little
bit of Down syndrome maybe you leave me
W me a new study out lens how a crappy
job can ruin your parenting style
parenting style so did you find that I I
kind of did agree with this yeah because
so what they're saying is that there's
this new study published in the American
psyche all Psychological Association
where they're saying it's a pretty big
journal I totally believe that cuz my
dad worked in a factory his whole life
and my dad was like the mark on you mean
was yelling angry all the time dad never
until we grew up and then now he's like
chill what kind of factory and what did
he do he was a machinist so he worked it
out auto like a like a car factory so it
was like the worst sure cuz I worked in
a factory for a summer yeah and it's the
worst job it's like hell every single
day
and I work from like 11:00 p.m. to 7:00
a.m. all the night relationships and
there's only Indians and Chinese like
night and is it like you know Eminem's
job in any mouth or just like carrying
my olive it's exactly that it's exactly
that and it's like it's only immigrants
working and then all the supervisors are
all white and they're just they hate
like immigrants they're just like always
threatening to take the jobs away
they're just so everyone's all the
supervisors are so racist like blatantly
racist and you couldn't really say
anything because you lose your job
because it like will then go [ __ ]
yourself like somebody somebody else
could work for your job be equally as
happy either take my [ __ ] or whatever
and I was like where am I like what is
this work
and like I just like I got to appreciate
my parents way more both my bed would
put up some [ __ ] and I was like oh this
is why they're always like just sad and
angry cuz that was taken yeah did you
realize this 1700 17 and now I got the
job next summer
yeah I worked and I only had like four
other friends cuz we all worked in the
5p then and we all had parents that
worked in the same Factory I had the
opposite experience my mom where I work
my [ __ ] ass off for you and my mama
taking me to work and I'm like so you
just sit in this air-conditioned off o
hours I'm like wha she bosses around all
the white people there know this job is
depressing then like it's it's like damn
and I have it like an easy job all I did
was like stamp parts on her brake parts
but the supervisor did not give a [ __ ]
like they don't give you any safety
equipment ID to work with like harsh
chemicals to wipe off things and he
didn't care he's like just wipe it and
then like I got day later another like
we call them aunties like a holder
Indian woman she came just like what are
you doing I'm like a wiping and she's
like you don't have gloves the few mask
the I were I'm like no she's like super
Iseman give it to you I'm like no he's
like look at your face it melt it off
look at the reflection oh [ __ ] red and
like fussing and I was like I don't know
I had nobody taught me this if she was
like what did you not know there's your
sixth finger and she then she asked the
supervisor didn't tell him he's a guy
he's he should have figured it out and I
was like what am I like what the [ __ ]
where am I so I just it was the wildest
experience I got a Joschka packed her
okay
Oh God
yeah so this study here though so they
they had 146 working mothers surveyed
along with their spouses and they were
asked about their experiences with rude
co-workers or bosses and then they act
they were asked about how their styles
and effectiveness of parents like
affected the kids and stuff so they were
saying that what they found is women who
experience incivility at work which is
like rude disrespectful impolite or just
things that violate workplace norms
those women were more likely to be way
more strict with their kids and like
just way less patience and then that
would have negative effect yeah okay
I always say like the things have a
domino effect like whatever energy you
give out it's a ripple effect yeah I
mean people say oh keep working home
separate it's like we're human beings
not [ __ ] robots it's hard yeah we
don't yeah we can't like it rubs off on
you
yeah everything whatever happens at
school or the workplace will come home
and whatever happens at home will come
to the workplace like it's so [ __ ]
stupid to expect not that not to happen
I mean people will try to keep it
contained and stay professional but I
think it's [ __ ] hard that's true yeah
and then they're saying that this style
of parenting has been associated with
the variety of negative child outcomes
including associating obedience and
success with love aggressive behavior
outside of the home being fearful or
overly shy around others lower self
lower levels of self-esteem why does it
sound like just me as a kid by the Asian
kid me as a kid yeah so for depression
and anxiety and struggling with self
control what the [ __ ] yeah it's like
maybe it's not really like a like a
Asian or white thing but this sounds
like a low income like peers thing like
everyone that I grew up around it sounds
like if you had a shitty job and your
chitti coworker she took that home and
took it out on the kids but you know why
I think it's more Asian as well because
like we brought our culture here and
then it's like you can be white and have
a low income job but it'd still be a
little bit different than like having
traditional strict values and then also
having a shitty job and then it's like
double the yeah that's true yeah I mean
like I think the white generation that
do connect with us is the older like
Great Depression style yes sir because I
like Italians that came yeah yeah yeah I
mean everyone was an immigrant at one
point and just hearing their stories -
it sounds really similar but I think
it's more like we connect through class
more than anything yeah because there's
a lot of upper-class Asians that I've
ran into that I have no like connection
with because it's just I don't get it
they're like an alien oh they're like an
alien yeah and in their level of
discipline and all that it's pretty
hardcore still but it's nothing like
what we went yeah so I'm like man you
know what yeah it's like me seeing
Indian Americans you look like so rich
you have to car doors your garage is
your garage door any people get it who
got damn well we're better now but I
remember growing up pretty poor but then
we got better like at like ten eleven we
got a better house you know I do it one
too like ten I was pretty my best friend
was probably the poorest Indian that I
knew but his dad still worked at the
post office so he still had a government
job and I was still decent yeah yes my
dad saved money from like our poor years
and then finally all that saved money he
bought a nice house then we got into a
nicer neighborhood and then life got a
little bit better but then before that
even if Indians are poor like in
California they don't stay poor for very
long you'll never see a homeless Indian
person no like no regardless will still
work but the stereotype here in
California is like you know agent I mean
Indians they upper middle class real
quick you know they get the engineering
jobs or or the immigrant Indians that do
come here they come on those uh genius
visas where they're I mean like so
they're already like like top tier
Indians that come in and they're like
doing science work or whatever
minute I see it Indian in my class I
already know there's no way I'm gonna
get the highest score okay I am for a
like maybe like tenth best or something
there's like 10 Indian kissing that was
asian like you change the thrusting hey
easy she was the smartest like Indians
were British average Japanese that
[ __ ] the homeless Japanese dude um
well I'm already disappointed him
alright me Japanese I don't know but I
know which one you're talking about mr.
Harrell the center thing in over there
well took yeah that little talk I'm
assuming he's Japanese but I'm already
mad disappointing their mouth I've never
seen a homeless Asian person nor a
homeless Japanese person
we got a please music great no no no no
nothing he's talking about old or
younger
no he's young he's like he could be in
his 20s or early 30s is it the guy we
saw in front of the udon place yeah the
guy that keeps walking in a circle yeah
NEP he I don't know he just never he's
always not like as told hanging out but
here's the thing though like moody born
here hmm was he like born he's bored
here that's why you know American
laziness but yeah my friend has a
clothing shop out there and then he said
that he's offered him like shoes new
clothes all that stuff and he's like my
story won't be as convincing if I look
good so no thanks so then you're just
you're just sinking in your own misery
at that point you know it's a it's a
it's a it's a scam like right a lot of
those guys he says they make on a good
day two to four hundred bucks a day yeah
just asking for money from tourists so
what do they do with the money drugs
that's better than an absence sometimes
not all of them though you know
yeah because drugs are expensive yeah
Wow America Gillian more now it's a very
unique area because we're right next to
skid row and Skid Row is just it's a
completely different beast it's not like
like homeless like in Sacramento San
Francisco or anything else
la is homeless in that specific area
it's it has a lot to do with drugs
that's not just like a stereotype or
anything that's just back like crazy
underworld people that died from like
all these like new synthetic drugs are
developing over there because they're so
poor they're like dying on the streets
it's pretty sad and there's more
homeless here because the the weather as
well yep it's a more habitable
yeah we have a study here talking about
working mothers and being more strict on
their kids yeah I totally related to
this to it especially being the kid of a
stressed-out mom and being a
stressed-out mom and doing that tonight
like being strict with my kid I'm like
oh [ __ ] this is totally just used to
punch Isaac in the face all the time it
was terrible
and now she's just bang sent straight to
you beating a child you need to stop
hitting him okay no that didn't happen
she's sue sue I feel like at times
though sometimes strict isn't so bad if
you're in a bad neighborhood oh yeah
there's there's been like a study where
in social psych I'm not a hundred
percent sure how this went down but it's
kind of like if your parents are super
strict in the ghetto it's actually good
for you because you're - yeah like like
Jill situation but if your parents are
too strict in like a upper-middle-class
it's actually worse for you because
you're not getting access to afterschool
Pro like they're not you're not being
exposed to the world yes so then it's
kind of like you know yeah I'm scared
what are you scared just Tyco cuz I
gonna be raised me and him we're we're
gonna be raised so completely
differently I think you'll be fine
you're gonna you're gonna be like you
[ __ ] privileged ass kid enough but
but we only raised them the way we were
raised in the way that it made sense to
us so you gotta punch him in the stomach
I was never punched in the stomach um
but then at the same time like we have a
very liberal like lifestyle way of thaw
like we're more into the are it's like
you know it's just so different
so this face is so different so I raised
my kid like a little good clothes money
Christian I'm gonna do exactly what my
parents did and be missing
[Laughter]
[Music]